[Applaudissements]
derrière une façade de restaurants sans
âme d'un centre commercial de la salle
des symboles de la culture ouïghours ont
trouvé refuge des d'opa chapeau
traditionnel rigourd aux instruments de
musique comme le rababou du doubs tard
tout y est pour rappeler non sans
douleur ses origines à tour sonne rosie
lui qui a fui la chine in extremis avec
sa femme et ses enfants
j'ai est arrivé canaux d'un simple annie
et singles année massa son frère n'est
pas parler j en ai pas parlé d un
penseur
montfrin ces quelques photos c'est tout
ce qui lui reste de sa famille dont une
dizaine de membres sont portées
disparues toute ma famille est en prison
affirme t-il ils subissent tortures et
violences physiques et moi je vis dans
un pays libre comme le canada mais ma
douleur psychologique et les la otage
dans un pays libre pour qui la pilule
des jeux olympiques ne passe pas
olympique lyonnais me même s'il dit
aimer les jeux olympiques qui ne
comprend pas pourquoi on passe sous
silence la situation des droits de la
personne en chine
la cause ouïgoure telium kassymov s'y
consacre à temps plein au concert en
famille qui compte après quarante
personnes disparues dans certains 60
personnes disparues pour qu'une vain
pendant le dernier 4,5 à la chine a
durci ses pratiques envers l'ensemble de
sa population les voies chinoise
dissidentes sont emprisonnés les
minorités réprimée selon ce professeur
en droit les we go or qui font l'objet
de mesures qui correspondent à des
violations massives et systématiques des
droits de la personne il ya aussi le
tibet qui continue on en parle moins
mais les mêmes pratiques de
d'effacement des cultures minoritaires
et des langues minoritaires continue a
hong kong la loi sur la sécurité
nationale à museler toute opposition à
la ligne politique gouvernementale le
même jeu pc contre la démocratie les
droits de la personne et aussi de la
liberté de la presse à hong kong c'est
vraiment incroyable que les jeux
olympiques a qu'un pas à avoir lieu
quand même le canada fait partie des
rares pays occidentaux qui ont décidé
d'un boycottage diplomatique des jeux
olympiques un geste qualifié de purement
symbolique à certains égards c'est vrai
que c'est symbolique mais par ailleurs
sa s'attaque aux jeux olympiques qui
sont eux mêmes un symbole est la raison
pour laquelle la chine souhaite
avoir les olympiques chez elle c'est
justement le symbole de l'importance
sinon de la centralité de la chine a
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui tour sonne a
choisi la cuisine ouigours pour
transmettre un peu de sa culture aux
canadiens et il travaille fort pour
apprendre celle de sa terre d'accueil
c'est maintenant je aller les comptes
pour une cessation
cheikh maintenant après décors
travaillés l'instant
en attendant de pouvoir revoir sa
famille tour sonne projets de grandes
espérances pour ses enfants son fils
joue déjà dans l'équipe de soccer de son
école secondaire sa fille envisage des
études universitaires en sociologie
après son cégep ici s1000 khayat radio
canada montréal